bonsoir à tous et retour au village des
jeux en compagnie de norbert de laurence
et de leurs deux magnifiques cob normand
ils vont qu'ils viennent pour le plus
grand plaisir du public et pour le nôtre
aussi
j'en profite pour vous annoncer une très
bonne nouvelle la france a décroché sa
toute première médaille dans ces jeux
équestres mondiaux mais c'est frank
biller qui doit vous en parler tout de
suite dans le résumé du jour
la première médaille française de ces
jeux et les applaudissements du public
du stade d'ornano pour les cavaliers de
l'équipe de france d'endurance c'est au
finish que s'est jouée ce titre par
équipes après 160 kilomètres d'un
parcours éprouvant dans la baie du mont
saint michel à l'arrivée des espagnols
termine 12 minutes avant les français la
consigne de départ c'était d'abord on
rentre au propre vraiment puisse
repartir lendemain se promener sans
problème et donc il n'était pas question
de faire prendre de risques aux taureaux
et la sort était prendre de risque que
d'aller chercher cette médaille d'or
retenez bien son nom
romuald ward ce bourguignon a réalisé un
véritable exploit en se qualifiant pour
la finale individuelle du reining son
étalon de 8 ans paix peace ruff a fait
une véritable démonstration dans ses
fans stop ce césar est en pleine course
il y aura donc un tricolore dans le top
20 9 concours pour l'instant dominé par
les américains et les belges les cowboys
français sont prêts à vous faire tourner
la tête en par adressage la lyonnaise
anne frédérique royaume était la
dernière chance de médaille pour la
france dans cette discipline
cette cavalière de 36 ans devenu
tétraplégique pensée ne jamais remonter
à cheval
elle décroche aujourd'hui la 8e place du
concours
j'avais envie d'une jument un peu plus
plus électrique un peu plus
dans le move comme ça et là est
exactement comme ça je me suis vraiment
fait plaisir je me suis amusé n'y avait
pas de pas d'objectif enfin je les monte
un petit peu plus comme à l'entraînement
et en plus ce beau soleil c'était super
cet après midi c'est quasiment une
légende de l'équitation qui s'est lancé
dans le concours complet au haras du pin
jean teulère 60 ans cette année champion
olympique par équipes en 2004
le cavalier fait parler son expérience
et se positionne déjà en vue du cross
qui aura lieu demain matin
et puis cette image même de la brutalité
charlotte dujardin qui a confirmé cet
après midi sur le dressage en musique
qu'elle était bien la star de cette
première semaine de juin
et pour finir quelques images de horse
ball en démonstration cette année le
tournoi se poursuit au centre hippique
de saint lô dans une ambiance survoltée
on trouve de tout au village des indiens
des cowboys
ils vont faire leur show dans quelques
instants mais pour l'heure c'est une
toute autre épreuve très attendu que
nous avons suivi en coulisses le
concours complet épreuves dites la plus
difficile des sports équestres au
programme du dressage du cso et le
favori le cross repérage avec l'équipe
de france
l'équipe de france du concours complet
au grand complet c'est le cas de le dire
passent au peigne fin les 6 km 500 du
parcours du haras du pin décryptage sous
tous les angles voir les pieds dans
l'eau des 45 obstacles sont des calculer
la distance exacte au millimètre près
c'est des repères pour nous c'est que si
on respecte nos minutes on doit arriver
dans le temps idéal à emporter
en parlant de temps mais celui du ciel
cette fois la météo normande plus
qu'incertaine nourrit les inquiétudes
des cavaliers tricolores
si le temps se tient comme ça on devrait
quand même avoir un terrain un bon
terrain ça va pas être allé vraiment
très bien drainés cette piste-là mais
pour l'instant ça devait se courir
aujourd'hui effectivement on serait dans
21 lourd et là ça se complique encore
plus le le cross long avant de
s'attaquer aux obstacles du parcours
un défilé pas comme les autres les
mannequins en duo couple cheval cavalier
passe au scanner visuelle des
vétérinaires
tout le clan français passent avec
succès l'obstacle médicale je suis
toujours au village à proximité de la
grande carrière de démonstration et je
suis en compagnie dans ledit booth le
plus français des australiens bonjour on
dit bonjour alors vous possédez une
rareté dans le monde et cas qu'on
appelle un horse exercer salle a
expliqué nous sommes si peu elle
s'appelle hausse parce que c'est moitié
zèbres montilliers hausse en anglais
donc motifs cheval
c'est ce thème au sahara ce qui est très
pratique c'est un peu comme si on
mélange un loup avec avec un chien il
est toujours mon pied sauvage donc elle
reste toujours avec cette moitié sauvage
est jamais vraiment réussi de maîtriser
mais on arrive de faire des choses quand
même ma du chat muzeau a par exemple bon
élément stable donc c'est déjà dans les
zébrés des hausses comme elle le leur
aide est remonté c'est très très rare
le but n'est pas de se développer cette
race certainement pas
c'est un mot pas au contraire de
beaucoup de races qui sont ici on
démonstration c'est plutôt beau dire on
ne fait pas ça mais mais on peut si on
peut arriver à éduquer ça peut-être tout
le monde peut arriver avec le chevaux ce
qui à comprendre comment le sera la
france merci pourquoi on dit merci
beaucoup
on passe un sujet très délicat le dopage
si les cavaliers sont contrôlés l'effort
porte surtout sur les chevaux l'une de
nos équipes a pu exceptionnellement se
rendre sur une zone de prélèvement
accompagner tout de même par une caméra
de la fcei la fédération internationale
les recherches se font à l'issue de
prélèvements d'uriné de sang sur chaque
épreuve plusieurs chevaux sont tirés au
sort
des contrôles sont systématiquement
effectués sur les quatre premiers des
podiums individuels et par équipes pour
les jeux les échantillons sont envoyés
sous haute protection dans un
laboratoire français et les résultats
connus en 48 heures pour la fcei le
sujet est très sensible
l'année dernière a été une année record
au nombre de contrôles en cinq ans le
nombre de contrôles positifs à baisser
ainsi en europe l'an dernier nous avons
eu une moyenne de 6% de tests positifs
c'est le taux le plus bas que nous ayons
eu depuis de nombreuses années reste à
connaître le nombre de chevaux contrôlé
sur ces jeux un chiffre que la f8 tient
à garder secret et qui se situerait
entre 15 et 30% des participants
cette première semaine des jeux
équestres mondiaux touche à sa fin
tranquillement programme varié ce
week-end avec du reading du jumping du
cross et du horse ball de quoi
satisfaire tous les publics
alors bon week-end et surtout bonne
rentrée
m
l'otan touchant